ladies and gentlemen the official poster
has finally been unveiled for spider-man
no way home asked a couple people to
send me a text when it comes out that
way i could just pull it up here on
google chrome and take a look at it and
we could react to it
real time so we haven't seen it yet
let's pull it up i'm very excited for it
going to twitter i'm sure it's there
somewhere all right and that's the first
thing from the from spiderman no way
home all right gonna pull it up hit him
full screen one two and
oh okay it's it's similar to the bus one
but there's some differences on here yes
okay so you got the dock you got greek
goblin back there
now this is actually our first real
glimpse at green goblin looks like he's
got a helmet on he's got a mask on
because there are a lot of things going
around and whether or not he would
actually have a mask on yeah and you got
some of that red that was coming in from
the doctor octopus tentacles that was
being pointed out when people were doing
empire magazine breakdowns of those
photos
could be possibly from the what is how
can we never commit to america
it could be that but what was the the
device he was the tritium the tritium
yeah all right looks like it could also
be sort of replicated from that where
the colors kind of look reflective of
that dr strange spell that you see in
the trailer so it could be hinting at
that like breaking through the
multiverse but that suggests at least a
clear transition because if the
tentacles are yellow on this poster and
they're gonna be reddish later there's
gotta be some kind of metamorphosis
there i mean is that just from like the
freeway rubble from when he's like
popping uh it might be for doc ock it
could just be a reference to the freeway
rubble part of what you see in the
trailer when he's coming up from the
ground yeah i think that's fair you got
some of that rebar protruding from the
cement in the iron spider suit but he
doesn't have the actual spider legs
protruding out oh god is there any
detail here that we're missing john
like where's there like some lizard
scales or something you're right that's
a sick poster that's much better than
the one that was on the bus and it's
definitely different yeah
yeah you can see the the design the
similarities but it's a lot more
intriguing and i mean you got green
goblin in the background like that yeah
that's worth the entire poster yeah man
this is like the i mean one thing we
don't have is just anything of the
lizard unless there's something that we
are completely missing
but this is a striking ass poster i like
this one a lot yeah yeah so much better
than i was like what if it's exactly the
one from the bus well it's cool that
it's just spiderman in the middle like
there are lots of hints and yeah you
have villains and whatnot but it's all
kind of centered on yes spiderman and
it's still completely alluding to um the
sinister the multiple at least yeah we
just need a little bit of lizard in here
for further confirmation yeah all right
guys but what did you think about that i
mean i did not notice a way late that
was the first thing you noticed yes
guys thank you so much for uh being here
keep a lookout for more videos we got
coming out this week spider-man more
spider-man coverage subscribe click that
bell hit that like button we'll catch
you guys soon